how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe
yesterday i talked about a possible
delay in the falcon and the winter
soldier with it possibly coming in
january or february in 2021
but now unfortunately it looks like
there could be a delay in the entire
phase four slate in general
we have a report from a very credible
source that says marvel studios is
looking
at pushing back black widow from its
november release date
and unfortunately since it is coming
from such a reputable source this does
seem likely at this point which means
the entire phase 4 slate will have to
move back as well as black widow is
going to be the first movie to be
released so i'll break down
this new report in this video but first
if you're new be sure to subscribe so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
mcu news
and so you can enter this week's
giveaway for a chance to win a hulk
funko pop just subscribe like the video
and comment down below so this report is
coming from deadline again a very
reputable news outlet
this news actually comes in the form of
a report from deadline about wonder
woman 1984
moving from its october release date in
their report they said that wonder woman
1984's release date is moving and it
could be moving
somewhere in november of this year and
then they specifically go on to say
there is a possibility we could see
wonder woman 1984
going somewhere in november yes
november there are whispers and disney
would not confirm today
that its marvel movie black widow could
move from its november 6th
release date so deadline basically just
said they heard that marvel studios is
going to move black widow
but they reached out to disney and asked
them and they didn't get a response
but deadline has reported that they've
heard whispers that it is going to move
and most of the time as many people can
assume when somebody reaches out to a
studio that has a very credible
relationship with them
looking for a response and they don't
give one that usually means that
whatever they're looking for
is actually true so that does kind of
point to marvel studios decision to
actually move
black widow from its november release
date now obviously this
is unfortunate and the fact that it's
moving back even more
means that the possibility for it to go
straight to video on demand gets even
bigger now
especially if you compare the
performance of mulan to
tenant disney released mulan on their
new video on demand service premier
access disney plus
over the weekend and tenant also
premiered over the weekend as well
bringing in
20 million dollars but mulan brought in
at least
33 million dollars with 1.1 million
households watching so even though
tennent was supposed to be and probably
still will be one of the biggest movies
of all time
due to the fact that people still aren't
returning to the theaters even though
they are open in a lot of places now
mulan still outperformed it on disney's
premier access
and disney's ceo did say they were going
to watch how mulan did this was
basically a test dummy and he basically
said that if mulan performs well they
will consider putting other movies on
vod
video on demand on their disney plus
premiere access so
the fact that tennant which was supposed
to be an insanely
huge movie didn't bring enough people
back to the movie theaters because it
did bring people back but not enough
because mulan a movie that you could buy
at your home and watch at your home
beat it so this combined with deadline
reporting that they've heard whisperings
that marvel is going to move black widow
back
again does seem to be pushing black
widow more and more towards a disney
plus
premier access release and we should
know something pretty soon there's been
a ton of reports today about wonder
woman 1984
possibly getting that november release
date so if this gets confirmed soon
marvel studios should be making a move
soon but as always leave your thoughts
about this in the comments down below i
know a lot of people want the theater
release i know a lot of people would
like a disney plus release but let me
know what you think in the comments down
below don't forget to like this video
and subscribe so you can stay up to date
on all the latest
mcu news as always thank you all so much
for watching woof
you